bis vor kurzem liefen hier noch die
bergungsarbeiten der geparkten fahrzeuge
die hier beschädigt worden sind bei
diesem unfall möglicherweise ein
illegales rennen schauen wir uns die
gegebenheiten an von dort kommt einen
kleinen kleinen wagen mutter tochter in
dem fahrzeug sie ordnen sich ein um hier
abzubiegen linksabbiegerspur um
abzubiegen auf den lehniner platz von
dort stadteinwärts kommen mutmaßlich
drei hoch motorisierte autos so sagen
zeugen eines dieser fahrzeuge rast ein
bmw rast hier mitten auf der kreuzung in
diesen kleinwagen mit mutter und tochter
drin
die überschlagen sich bleiben er dort
liegen auf dem dach und das
unfallfahrzeug fährt hier in die
geparkten fahrzeuge hinein beide
insassen der fahrer der beifahrer
flüchteten zu fuß stadtauswärts so die
berichte von augenzeugen die
rettungskräfte müssen erst das auto mit
mutter und tochter umdrehen um sie zu
bergen die mutter muss dann hier gleich
reanimiert werden so schwer sind ihre
verletzung wissen wir was über den
jetzigen zustand der beiden
da haben wir leider nur schlechte
nachrichten die beiden sie kämpfen
weiter ums überleben im virchow-klinikum
hier in charlottenburg liegt die mutter
45 und ihre 17-jährige tochter beide
nach wie vor in lebensgefährlichem
zustand da hoffen wir auf bessere
nachrichten aus dem klinikum am heutigen
tag